hey guys it's another kicking back with
Anna and Dave we are very excited about
the lighting right now we did a little
stuff outside you have to deal with the
Sun the natural but here we were able to
manipulate things yeah we're feeling
very good about it
all right I wanted to talk about the
WNBA which is obviously the Women's
National Basketball Association they
announced this week that they are going
to be the first professional sports
organization in the United States that's
gonna market directly to gay people now
it's been a good gay year as I thought
about on my Jo all the time every week
another state
we got Pennsylvania in Oregon this week
obviously in terms of sports Jason
Collins and the NBA Michael Sam was just
drafted in the NFL but this I think is
really interesting in this in a weird
way is like the biggest step because now
yeah ollars now it's like we are
particularly marketing to you so pretty
great right yeah I think it's great I
wonder if it's because no one watches
the WNBA that is a problem
I was gonna get to that yeah which sucks
but you know I don't watch basketball
period so it has nothing to do with
gender I'm just not interested in it I
know a lot of people are gonna be pissed
you and they're gonna say that they are
fans because they do have like a small
hardcore base but yeah I get it I get it
but it's not as big as the NBA you guys
right so yeah I mean it sucks but I
think it's because this is my
speculation this is probably gonna 50
that's you know it might be because they
don't have much to lose and maybe
they're like hey here's a market that we
can appeal to and maybe that will help
drive up viewership yeah so I definitely
think there is some truth to that and
obviously there's a lot of lesbian
players in the WNBA there's a lot of
openly lesbian players and I'm sure that
even beyond that that there's actually
way more still that don't publicly say
it or whatever and there been stories
about how that WMA was trying to sort of
mitigate the amount of people that were
coming out because they didn't want to
sort of be seen as a gay leave yourself
but is there something about this that
makes it a little more palatable for
mainstream America that it's about
yes that's actually a great point I
didn't even think about that look when
people talk about gay sex especially
Republicans they're never referring to
lesbians they're always referring to gay
men like some reason they have like this
visceral reaction to it because they're
usually doing it in the airport bathroom
and it's so on cleaning them and and so
and there is a double standard when it
comes to lesbians and gay guys because
lesbians they think like oh it's
beautiful it's sexy it turns me on with
gay men like for some reason they get
turned off by it so yeah maybe there is
that element to it yeah
and and I mean I think about the
reaction that people had to Michael Sam
after he shared a really tender moment
with his boyfriend after he got drafted
by the Rams I believe right
he was rented by the ramp right like
people you know had like and they had
reaction to it even though it was a
really beautiful moment there was
nothing wrong with it well that's the
funny thing because you know we've come
so far obviously and it's all great but
when when there was the reaction to the
kiss you know that's the next step the
next step of normalizing everything is
that a kiss is just a kiss you know so
you can't but yeah the next step if you
want before all these people that always
say well we want is to stop talking
about this stuff or well not when I do
videos on the Rubin report about gay
some people say what you talk about gay
stuff Leslie it's like it needs to just
sort of become what it is it needs to
just finish itself up and we're almost
there and believe me no one I don't know
if there will be anybody on earth that
will be happier to not talk about the
gay stuff than me when it has has that's
normalized so you have gay rights it's
equal rights month it's a it's not an
issue anymore and I think that we're
coming pretty close to that we are
coming pretty close do you agree do you
love the NBA do you love lesbians what
else I mean I like lesbians
and you guys